good morning Millennials welcome back to
another bright spritely fun young
hilarious episode of the morning toast
them alert well let's never know the
date it's July 31st oh my god it's my
first day and it's 10:30 1:00 a.m.
Eastern Time
uh how's everyone doing on this
beautiful morning oh sorry my volumes of
sister Wow how's everyone doing on this
beautiful morning we are doing well I
can't believe it's only Tuesday
yesterday was a very long day because we
were so productive such business today
it's like another productive day but
very different it's a different oh god I
think you cover your nose yeah of course
okay I come in your nose you sneeze into
your nose yeah oh actually you do
Sydney's out of your nose you're not
supposed to you're supposed to sneeze
out of your mouth when you sneeze out of
your nose that's when you hold it you
check I this is like the ad of my no
Jackie's like this only when I don't
have a tissue and I have a tissue it is
shofar season but when I really seize
its out of the mouth no that's no no no
oh my god I don't know I'm googling it
you sneeze out of your nose that's
elemental correct do you get a booze out
of nose or mouth google Katya you sneeze
out of your nose only cuz literally look
at the picture that comes up when you
google that it's a man spitting the goal
is to expel the irritant from the nasal
cavity nose from so you get it out of
the nasal cavity so at least a city's is
partly out of your nasal out of your
nose however because the cavity isn't
big enough alone to handle the release
most pretty much has to go out of your
mouth
hey guy we were both late but I'm like
its mouth a 70% nose is 30% right so I'm
telling you I can seize with my mouth
closed remember when they said if you
sneeze with your eyes open you would die
no we get stuck like you could die
anyways such a busy day in camp everyone
be like try and sneeze with our eyes
open I would never because why would I
want to get stuck like that he was
testing us we got a warning yeah yes sir
he was so busy when we filmed our
communities with Mercedes shopping from
Shahs of Sunset it looks so long ago you
know if you haven't listened to it yet
check it out in the podcast or she is
just an open book I love her so much
it's just falling more and more in love
with her and by the way
she's literally so pretty like her skin
is flawless and she just she gives
literally like I think I give no [ __ ]
homegirl gives no [ __ ] and it's
admirable uh-huh and she's had such swag
about her and I really really like her
she's like what repins live on Thursday
right after the premiere of a set of
shots with Reza so it's just gonna be
said we've got to get her ass on the
show oh my gosh we have got to get Reza
definitely appreciates the premium
content we serve up left right and
center he's in New York we got to get to
him
TBD stay tuned well you're not here
through the rest of the week it is a
Jackie O take over okay obviously
tomorrow I will be co-hosting with a
lien from betches Thursday I will be
co-hosting with Darren because we must
talk about the boat episodes airing on
Wednesday and then Friday it's Mitch on
the toast egg snitch on the toast
special guest not feel you can oh yeah
so Olympic gymnast it's gonna be so
crazy sitting here with someone with so
much talent and being like Mattel is
hack girl with no talent no with talent
oh she's like the most happiness it's
just like she bleeds talent today I mean
like no one in the entire world could
disagree with the fact that now CL you
can is talented I could definitely mind
a lot of people who would agree disagree
with the if I said I was talented you
know like I just don't think there's our
time it's definitely subjective like
less tangible it's open for debate
yeah but yeah so I'm very excited to sit
down with a girl with talent and pick
her brain so it's gonna be a jam-packed
week we will miss you sister I'm gonna
YouTube well the shop tomorrow morning I
feel like since this is your last show
today like we gotta make it a banner
let's make it one for the book it's
already gonna be a banger cuz Daniel
like Holtz from southern charm
Savannah's here and I just want to bang
him so whatever okay Derek er Daniel
Derek also like I definitely was acting
really inappropriate with Derek and like
it's so funny cuz Ben does not watch the
show and that's I know that he always
lies and says that he does but I know
that he doesn't because he would have
been like excuse me that can you stop
flirting with didn't he see it the
Instagram posting the memes he didn't
see he's just like so not in tune and
yesterday he someone must have sent him
a clip or he must have seen something
and he's like who is this guy that's so
I think what was your answer I was like
oh it's just like this prank
oh my goodness I mean I'm so excited for
Danielle today it's been like a year
since we saw him because he was our
first guest ever on the show he was our
first Skype guest and then he came back
IRL the same day as a packed her in
Paradise scandal so that was just a
really big day for us oh yeah I guess
he's the only guest who's now been here
three times has Corinne no cream white
rice
he's only where's that never been three
times that's wild well I have to let him
know yeah well that's good we're on the
good path cuz he bursts oh he's also the
first for the third that is so great
anyways without further ado we are here
to hit you with the Fast Five story
something you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast I love our sound effect no
it's great we should trade market yeah
cuz everyone's stealing from us eat oh
yeah and good morning to all the thieves
out there oh yes good morning especially
to everyone who watches our show for
inspiration for their own content the
inspiration for plagiarism and you know
you should just start telling fakes
stories and putting out fake news oh my
god it's such that's like when Kim told
Jonathan a false story about her to see
if she was that he was the leak in her
camp and he wasn't and he was so
offended rightfully so it's like in Game
of Thrones when the bald man tells three
different people his strategy and then
he knows who the snitch is that's we
should do so I can't believe Kim and
Kris Humphries are back together okay
let's jump right in what are stories
okay very best they are robust I have to
be honest you guys playing stories today
was like pulling teeth not that much
it's happened which is good because in
this world no news is good news you know
I couldn't agree more stable things are
okay the kids are gonna be alright do
you ever see that movie no of course not
did you ever see that movie
I forget the name I think it was called
Chloe we're a menace II Frida and
Julianne Moore played lovers know it's
an incredible movie I kind of go out of
my way to avoid every Amanda Seyfried
movies victory I kind of go out of my
way to avoid every Julianne Moore movie
so did you see it I did because my
friend Lee say made me watch it in high
school and you just think it would have
been more popular just because it was
like sex scenes at the man to see for
you to end to where it's like who
wouldn't want to see that and like it
just like wasn't a popular movie and it
was like one of the girls Chloe was a
stalker or whatever is really good I
mean that's our next shutter island' no
no our next Island is this movie called
little children have you ever seen that
no what's it it is probably one of the
best movies I've ever seen and it's also
my friend at least yeah we got to it
together nice well
and it's Kate Winslet okay and the
doctor who lives in the brownstone from
girls what's his name by the movies
called Carol no it's not that's a
different movie okay the doctor who
lives in the brownstone from girls I
don't know he's called Lina but yeah
Patrick something he's in very random
things but he's so hot and kate winslet
plays this like housewife and there's a
pedophile who moves into the
neighborhood and like the whole
neighborhood isn't is up in arms but
kate winslet is so busy being in love
with her neighbor and having an affair
that like she can't be bothered but the
pedophile and into shutter island you
can't spoil it because if you had
spoiled shutter island like i wouldn't
be the same okay but i'm all i think
about it I do like movie of the week
we're like we [ __ ] cuz last week it was
shutter island' and this week it needs
to me this movie little children okay
you might have to buy it on Amazon
because it's like not that popular but
it is one of the most shocking movies
it's available to rent on Amazon we'll
go forward with movie of the week we'll
talk about it when you're back on Monday
are you back on Monday yes and if it's
not available we'll find something else
but I really like this movie at the
beginning but I really want to pay well
grounded movies you know and I want to
do like some more movies we gotta get
like knowing where to would like its ass
no actually no we definitely need to do
like a week dedicated to American Ashley
movies and we need to do perhaps because
it's the best movie it's shame we want
to start out like a little stronger we
started sharing we shot her I let know
the next I check you like really did
shape our lives
no I know what I'm talking about of
course I do I was there not to be nice I
got to get down there but we were
watching Bratz for like the hundredth
time when we found out that our dad died
yes so then that was temporarily ruined
yeah this is the last time when you
watch Daniel I watched it one more time
to kind of like break the scene I
watched it recently like six months ago
and it's [ __ ] fantastic you guys have
to see it it's I guess your good movie
that even the death of our Father
couldn't bring it down you know I just
hope while you're watching it your seat
better news totally wait so I would like
to officially nominate movie of the week
to what day is it Tuesday it's a great
day for movie of the week okay I'm gonna
talk about on Monday because you're not
here on Tuesday yeah I'm in Philly but
the weekends should be enough time for
everyone to watch it also you guys can
also watch at your desk that works I got
your dude totally on Amazon Prime not
probably on that flicks for free it's so
good by the way there's nothing on
Netflix so that would make sense it
wouldn't make sense that we're on
there's nothing on that like when I go
to watching Netflix I really just go
watch trailers and
and then I didn't go home I was slowly
moving back towards Amazon Prime and now
that I have a fire stick in Amazon it's
like the easiest one to access I'm
really obsessed but it's annoying you
have to pay for stuff but most of the
time it's worth it like I just bought
the most recent season of shark tank me
and jag were talking about it on the way
here
and honestly kudos shark tank for being
so in tune with what's necessary when it
comes to guest sharks like them having
Bethenny like was definitely a risky
choice because she's like a reality star
but like so she was so great she was
made for shark tank and shark tank was
great for her exactly Sara Blakely an
inspired choice I had no clue how rich
she was and I had no clue she owned a
hundred percent of her own company it's
a billion dollar company like I can't
believe that I started researching her
afterwards and a-rod is good too even
though it doesn't be more dynamic and
just ask people more than what their
background is but why would you think
he'd be more dynamic because he is just
like nasty no but because he's a legend
like it's like there's nobody more
famous in so many sectors you know you
know I agree Cameron Diaz but you know
what like it's nice to know that Ashley
it's you know her born like that he's so
talented and he also has like so many
successful business ventures you can't
have it all he can't also be interesting
right and smart but now I'm like so
invested in the kind of relationship and
the dynamic between the Sharks because
it's really interesting who they choose
to keep on always like Marc is in every
episode mr. wonderful is not in every
episode Laurie's in every episode Laurie
I've come to realize is the only person
who invest in things Laurie I think a
majority of her business
it's from the shark tank brands that she
creates and they feel like Laurie has
like a very robust system in place I
have a brand this is like this is the
strategy formula it will be successful
or ability and that's totally to hinges
on the brand being a good a good idea
where's the other sharks it's like they
don't have that they invest in kind of
like different they so every case is
like a one-off so it makes more less set
like I feel like they have to work
harder right I also feel like Mark Cuban
like his businesses that he invested in
Shark Tank are just like side things
whereas
Laurie's portfolio was so robust and I
think she takes this really seriously
and like the company she creates are
definitely making her like a lot of
money yeah she's the only one who invest
and mr. wonderful always puts out a deal
but it's always terrible Andy never gets
it Robert never utters a word right if
he does is always about the success of
tipsy else oh yeah one thing is it's
just come from
the chef because he eats all the food or
it's talking about his dad being an
immigrant for sure I just want to say I
love Robert I I do not like I just think
he's so sweet
wait by the way especially compared to
mr. one tracking to you and Robert have
the same wedding planner yes we do
because we have the same running now
we'll also have the same wedding
photographer I had the same
photographers Robert perspective um in
the episode that photo booth that the
Cardassians loved murmur came on for and
they didn't get one which I thought was
weird but Robert was like when you guys
on my wedding and they were like yeah
they're like oh that's so funny I didn't
even see you guys or using but my
planner Mickey
Mikey and I was like wait that's check
his planner and then I knew that we both
had the same photographer I'm like
there's probably it's probably yeah and
I met Mikey through the photographer Wow
and next step we'll just meet the
Herjavec yeah Kim call us I think they
would like us I feel like they would to
work but I'm also we should go on Shark
Tank okay so I was thinking like if I
had like a tangible but like a fit like
a product there's no doubt I would work
extra time to get on our chart and then
I'm like wait I kind of do have yeah but
I don't know it's like it's too New Age
like they're just starting to take
pitches of like apps no I agree but I
feel like when they get pitches that are
like social media base especially like a
female owned brand and a very
forward-thinking
it's like so much of what they don't
know that they're so interested in it
and honestly I don't even know if we've
got a deal I don't even know if we need
a deal cuz like we are I don't know what
more money right go for the show so I
don't think I think the only flaw in our
business is the most important one that
they say it's like we don't have a
revenue model like the show's free if we
put on shows and we're gonna sell merch
but like we don't this isn't like a
business yet to the point where it's
like we have profit do you know what I
mean I guess I don't know it would have
to help us like I find me new revenue
ways but like they hate that like they
want there to be money to be made I I
agree with that but I think it would
just be interesting TV and we would just
be an interesting pitch cake yes and
that's what a lot of shark tank is to
just finding interesting brands and it's
not even about the deal it's just like
but be good for TV totally I think we'd
be a good brand we should on if anyone
out there produces shark teams we
obviously do though stars in the world
we'd have to do our pitch like in our
set like this we'd be like good morning
sharks cut
good morning sharks hi my name is
Claudia RI also known as girl with no
job and I'm Jackie a shy Jackie O
problems if he couldn't tell we're
sisters and this is the morning toast
the Millennial morning show do you feel
misrepresented as a millennial in
daytime television
why yes Claudia I do well I boy do I
have a thing for you it's the morning
toast Monday through Friday we go live
on Facebook and YouTube we're also
available as a podcast for those
creators out there and we just talk
about the things that Millennials who
really care about Kardashians yes Bravo
yes The Bachelor yes NATO no catch my
drift mark we think of investment in the
morning toast would be delicious for you
and for us we're here seeking 7 million
dollars for a 2 percent stake in our
company
sharks who wants to jump aboard the
morning toast to tune that's good Wow
okay so you send that to the producers
and let someone clip that and just tweet
it up well have your people call us yeah
because we don't have people okay ready
for the past I stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your mouth oh no we have not I
started to and then of course we got
derailed of the cloud burning derailment
honestly H we called the morning engine
no I think we considered that along with
greeting Millennials Kim Kardashian was
naked when Donald Trump called a naked
Kim Kardashian for a Steven Klein
photoshoot I was naked when President
Donald Trump called her wait
I'm making her - she was naked I must've
missed a word in there okay lobby for 63
year old grandmother Alice Marie Johnson
who was sentenced to life in prison for
a first-time nonviolent drug offense in
1996 Kardashian 37 recalled the moment
when the commander-in-chief phoned her
she said it during an appearance on
Jimmy Kimmel Live on Monday he called me
Kardashian again so I was at a Steven
Klein photo shoot and if anyone knows
who he is it's pretty much a nude shoot
so I'm naked and my phone rings and I'm
all glammed up and I'm like get me a
robe and I was waiting for the call not
knowing when it was going to come even
if it was it and it was it that doesn't
really make sense Kardashian Kardashian
said she put on a robe and was kind of
bugging out during the shoot noting how
all these amazing things are happening
when it rains it pours when it rains
pull the Keeping Up with the Kardashians
star visited Trump's 72 at the White
House in May adding the gravitas of the
Oval Office left her in awe I walk in
and I look around and I'm kind of
starstruck by the Oval Office she said
and the first thing I say in our meeting
I say holy [ __ ] we're in the [ __ ]
Oval Office following the meeting both
Kardashian
Trump took to Twitter to address their
discussion quote I would like to thank
president Trump for his time this
afternoon it is our hope that the
president will grant clemency to miss
Alice Marie Johnson who was serving a
life sentence for a first-time
nonviolent drug offense Kardashian
tweeted May 30th shortly after the
meeting Trump granted clemency to
Johnson so I actually the other day was
thinking about Alice Murray Johnson how
like her story was so big and then the
second she got out like he was dead
silent and like I'm like that's great
like she's not out here thirsting for
Instagram followers like she's home with
her grandchildren like I never been more
happy to go an Instagram is right I've
never been more happy to realize like
Alice Michonne sin' like went missing
because like she's living her life right
it's like her life she was promised you
know I totally agree I just like I don't
think I'll ever get over the whole thing
me neither and I feel like Kim sleeps so
well at night knowing that like
regardless of all the [ __ ] all the
things that people say about her whether
or not you agree with the things that
she does in her career in her apps and
her products or whatnot like she changed
a woman's life she changed a family
forever for the better and you know what
like that's all we can hope to do in
this world it's just changed one
person's life that's so true she changed
my life so that she did but like in your
life we've never changed someone's life
I actually do you do who um I mean I
don't I can't like put my finger on like
one person right now but I feel like I'm
I always try and go out because I'm not
that I'm like a great nice person all
the time but I feel like I really can
symbolize with like people sometimes and
I feel like I don't know like in college
like I don't know I feel like I feel
like I've helped people I feel like I
have not like I couldn't I feel like a
few times in my life I've really gone
out of the way to like make someone feel
special and like who was feeling like
really down yeah that's really sad cuz I
can't pinpoint a moment where I've ever
been like super nice to someone who
needed it but then again I also have
dementia it's like maybe I didn't I just
forgot about it for sure that's and you
also never know like what people like
think about when they see your Instagram
like we got so many kind messages that's
true oh and I can think of one toaster
whose life that we can make sure city
I'm home girl now I can think of two
toasters EMD when I almost died in my
sleep remember and they told me I'm
literally welcome to middle tonight
choking and I never go to the doctor so
I went to City MD which I don't know if
they have in every city it's basically
like a storefront doctor and it's like
legit so I went and like I just almost
died
um and I was just like telling the story
very dramatically on the toast and I
guess I let this girl know who lives in
New York about CityMD she had no I
didn't she like had a bad headache and
she went turns out she had a brain tumor
and like literally saved lives
yeah and then there was another toaster
who I know it was like really second
like the toast I can helped her get
through her treatment and then there are
just all the toasters whose life is
enhanced by the show so I don't water
cooler right but I don't know that we've
changed your lives don't even hands your
eyes and I feel good about the work that
we do you know what we're enhancers
we're like you know where you have a
photo and then there's a live that
little magic wand that it enhances
that's us we're not you know we're like
we're we're brightness we're a filter
yes we're preset we're X Pro I need
presets you guys like I have them but
you don't know how to use them so
presets it's like then this new trend
that you know like Brielle's pictures at
a mana stand these pictures all look the
same it's like this gray grainy
undertone it's because there's this
photographer who sells presets and it's
like it's a filter that you put on every
one of your photos and I was at a party
he was talking I'm like wait are you
Thai friend she's like yeah my presets
he's like what like he couldn't believe
someone knew his piece and I was like
yes [ __ ] I love them so he gave it to
me for free and the way to use them and
download them I can't even understand so
I have them I got them for free and I
don't know what you think I'm about to
buy like a schmuck like a package of
presets just wait no but I don't even
know how to use them I will buy them and
it's like you have to get can't put a
price on premium kind of to get the Dory
Lightroom and like I'm we're not a Joby
we're not a duo but if I can't turn on
my phone I'm not interested and you have
to be by a computer to download them yes
so no thank you no thank you anyways
anyways moving on to the next story this
one's for you okay because you don't
know I'm are you drinking news to me
right now I'm breaking news to you about
your favorite song bebe Rexha and
Florida Georgia line break country chart
record Wow it was just meant to be pop
singer bebe Rexha and country do at
Florida Georgia line's massive crossover
hit meant to be has broken a new record
on Billboard's Hot Country Songs chart
remaining in the number one spot for 35
weeks so billboard reports the song
which was duly promoted to country and
pop radio past Sam Huns previous
powerhouse body like a back road which
held the record for 34 weeks in 27
team you know what I'm curious when they
did cruise with Nellie that was like the
biggest country song to ever happen did
it make it
oh that topped the charts for 24 weeks
in 2012 and 2013 well and also their
song holy spent 18 weeks at number one
that's crazy though honestly well-earned
I do feel like body like a backroad is
more of a country song
not even country song but just like a
musically impressive song but you know
what a good song is a good song and if
people are enjoying it and it's bringing
joy to so many morning show host and on
the off chance that you don't know what
the song sounds like it goes a little
something like this I don't mean to be
so uptight but my heart's been heard a
couple times by a couple guys that
didn't treat me right I ain't gonna lie
gonna lie cuz I'm tired of the fake love
show me what you made a girl make me
believe you're come after y'all hold up
girl don't you know you're beautiful and
it's easy to see if it's not to be it'll
be it'll be baby just let it be if it's
meant to be it'll be it'll be baby just
let it be
so won't you ride with me ride with me
see where this thing goes
harmony if I can't be what I got it
right why am i if it's meant to be it'll
be it'll be who is that Mason Ramsey on
the red carpet he was hard on you ever
see the video no I guess not oh my god
honestly I'm really upset with me sim
because he did this whole promo if you
buy his EP and you sent him
screenwriting a message him he'll send
you a t-shirt and like of course like I
should mark I did it and I can tend to
use schmuck today just because I'm a big
snob yeah one of the day totally because
I buy presets and I enter me some Ramsey
contests and I didn't get one and I
messaged him like every hour cuz he was
doing it every hour and I really tried
and I wrote like really everyone was
gonna get it no he's picking like a
winner every hour or ten winners every
hour and like I just felt like I
deserved it like he doesn't even know
how hard I work for him and that's
frustrating dad no no it's real
like we recognized the toasters who
worked so hard for us and like I just
feel like he's not it's important to
measure Truffaut the maisonette who
worked so hard for him um just really
quickly back to meant to be not only is
it a great song I'm just like so here
for Phoebe rocks maybe rocks echoes I
feel like singers who are like pop stars
or like anyone in like R&B or rap they
like look down on country music like I
think that they they don't consider it
like a real music genre and that like
the people who listen to it like aren't
real but like literally country songs
listen to so much more than like an
average like pop song so like I'm just I
love when a it's the same way I feel
about exactly I'm embracing his musical
theater vibes I love just went a pop
start embraces her country side I agree
you didn't watch Real Housewives of
Orange County last night but first of
all it was it was crazy but not in the
great way we could talk about in a
little bit but Tamra's talking about
what she's drinking so much she's like I
have so much going on in my life I could
write a country song my husband's heart
broken and I need a shot of tequila
those countries I know totally
then always tries to write country songs
and he's got a pretty good yeah it's
always like about a pickup truck and
like and water Janis yeah this is his
classic song ready we went out in the
yard me and sister Janet I told her that
I loved her more than anyone on this
planet and honestly like but it's it's a
it's a good song with it now I'm
thinking about it doesn't make sense
because it's sister John it's either
that's a nun or his sister
no it's about like his sister like I
feel like it was it's a song definitely
about like him going to the army so he's
like saying but goodbye that's how I
wish okay yeah
I don't ask me about it or it's about
incest like the song Sarah Beth is the
saddest song of her gypsy music with
Sarah about to scare to death to hear
what the doctor might say yeah she
hasn't been well since the day that she
fell and the bruise it just won't go
away or do you know the song here comes
goodbye of course here comes good bad no
country sounds like I feel like a pop
song and rap songs are just about like
[ __ ] and titties whereas like country
songs are about like really should they
would say country songs are about beer
and pickup trucks me a lot of them are
but you need to listen to here comes
good bye when they played it at their
concert I was crying it's the best song
it's the best I that was reminds me of
cam speaking of camp we are working
overtime on cam toes we just got some
liability issues we're trying to work
through we're hopefully next week
hopefully August 6 that's a month out
okay well be
what a sell ticket okay but hopefully a
lot of you are coming are in the
tri-state area I know a few of you are
flying in which is great we're working
our hardest view and campus is happening
rain or shine but it's not supposed to
exist no but honestly even if it rained
I'm so all about whether it does not
stop fun and if it rains we would go mud
sliding we wouldn't all hang out in the
rec hall we'd be forced to be together
if you were gonna bring it all let it
pour right remember that episode of 30
rock that's the best episode when like
liz has a boyfriend and now she thinks
all the guys around her interested in
her and every time someone like says
something to her even if it's like hey
do you want a coffee
she's like she looks at the camera she's
like when it rains above 30 rock it's a
great show
I need a 30 rock yes yeah and we were in
the elevator singing do-do-do-do-do a
student when they did a lot I was crazy
in tune with what's necessary I love 30
rock the building 30 rock the show and
Jack Donaghy and Kenneth yeah you are
gonna that's so mean no I know
yeah maybe Olivia's watching 30 rock now
for the first time and she doesn't like
Kenneth I don't either but like Kenneth
is just so like sweet he's macing Ramsey
God Kenneth is a [ __ ] he's so annoying
I found everything with him to be more
annoying actually I wonder if I watch it
back now if I would still like Kenneth
he's infuriatingly stupid my favorite
it's always like every show Jane my
favorites Tracy he's literally thing
that comes out of his mouth it's like
put Donaghy yeah no but Tracy is like he
wasn't in the show nearly as much as I
needed him to be yeah okay and a horse
so I'm surrounded by a bunch of nice
okay we have to get through the show
because we have a dream guest and I want
to talk to him for a long time
okay next up Beyonce will be on Vogue
September cover Beyonce will be on the
cover of Vogue September issue fashion
sources told page six the singer was on
the cover of the vaunted September issue
in 2015 and has been on the cover of
Vogue issues in 2009 and 2013 we hear
the photographer will be Tyler Mitchell
in 2015 Mario Testino photographed
Beyonce but vogue did not interview the
icon who has increasingly controlled her
image meanwhile rumors continue to swirl
that the issue could be Anna Wintour's
last yeah there's a rumor going around
that this will be Anna Wintour's last
September issue and she's given up total
creative control to beyonce to pick her
photographer to do
her captions and cover style and why I
like the big story here isn't that
Beyonce's on the cover like congrats
she's a big star in the world like it
makes sense
it's that hopefully finally we've been
pregnant this might be Anna Wintour's
last cover right and like for her last
swan song she's really pushing control
like it's just so indicative of the kind
of community she's called today that
vogue right no control and apparently
beyonce is hiring the first black
photographer to take the cover photo
like a blackwell tiger has never taken
the cover photo but like Anna Wintour
again out of tune if it's necessary
totally I can't believe that in this day
and age it's still like Sandra Oh of
from Grey's Anatomy she is the first
Asian woman to be nominated for an Emmy
of like lead like how in 2018 are we
still having firsts it's like where is
our Jewish president you know like
that's never gonna happen but like I
just Kimberly there's still firsts for
like we have a Jewish first daughter
something converted to like come on we
need a Jewish president I'll do it oh my
god first of all I would kill so many
statistics I would be the first woman
president first Jewish president first
president to install a soda fountain
machine and actually Herbert Hoover had
one sorry first to install a frozen
yogurt machine first president first
chubby president because William Taft
was enormous not chubby I'm chubby I'd
be the first female president I don't
know I just feel like I'd be a lot of
firsts some down a few guys are I think
you would also be the shortest president
yes a hundred percent I'd be the only
president in history to I don't know
you'd be the youngest president Oh duh
I'd also livestream at the morning toast
on PBS because that's public television
goodness yes and Thea would be the first
first done and the first dog totally and
they always have a dog in the White
House hangout but they're never been ask
you to see oh no right Theo deserves the
White House he does also I was thinking
about a funny tweet that the White House
sent out when Obama was president about
their dog I'm trying to make fetch
happen it was really funny oh that's
good yeah it was in tune okay being in
tune there's nothing better nothing
better
next up the Big Mac is turning 50 I know
what our next movie of the week has to
be the founder it's too important but
let's let's we don't want to we can see
we have people from watching a little
children little children
this week the founder next week it's so
important about one of our nation's most
important legacies McDonald it's
honestly I made then watch it because
I've seen it now device it's literally
one of the most I had watched the gamut
of wild movies wild movies okay
McDonald's is fighting to hold on to
customers as the Big Mac turns 50 but it
isn't changing the makings of its most
famous burger I'm here for that the
company's celebrating the 1968 national
launch of the double decker sandwich
whose ingredients of two all-beef
patties special sauce lettuce cheese
pickles onions and a sesame seed bun
were seared into American memories by a
TV jingle but the milestone comes as the
company reduces its number of Us stores
McDonald's said at Thursday their
customers are visiting less often other
trendy burger options are reaching into
the heartland I just don't believe that
Big Mac I mean I just don't believe that
Burger King is a legitimate threat to
McDonald's no I can't burn I think it's
like in New York it's bare burger in
every city it's like real Ortiz and
people are done eating frozen meat and I
just want to be honest with mcdonnell's
like I don't eat there that often
because I don't eat non-kosher meat but
like if you had a kosher patty I would
eat I would eat big on Atkins I would go
and get a Big Mac every day and take out
the bun I would eat that every single
day I just like I absolutely I'm in love
head over heels with McDonald's and
there was a time period like a couple
months ago where I ordered it every day
for lunch after the toast like because
on overeats it makes it so easy and it's
across the street and like when I'm
really hungry and like I can't wait for
food it comes like literally in seven
minutes and it's just so good always
they need a veggie burger ya know they
should definitely have a kosher patty in
New York like I don't know I mean that
would be amazing they have kosher
McDonald's in Israel and it's literally
amazing I would eat there every day so I
feel bad advocating for McDonald's when
I can't even eat there that much but if
they went had they have a kosher
McDonald's in the ll in the Israeli
Airport and in Jerusalem yeah and it's
heavenly divine and an amazing heavenly
divine and amazing so either a kosher
patty or a veggie burger cuz like they
should actually have a veggie burger
anyway because the only vegetarian
option they have is fish leg which is
the scariest ocean on it and I ordered
it when we were in Nashville cuz I was
like I want McDonald's welcome
McDonald's yeah we were so fat like yeah
we it was quiet so took the last time I
remember that big jug of mac and cheese
oh my god yes wow that was really
embarrassing no I ordered a fish fillet
like that's how by oh remember eating
McDonald's were we drunk we had to have
been it was late night okay anyways
go for a veggie burger but I'm really 50
years of the Big Mac that's exciting
it is no honestly McDonald's is so
American and it has like deep roots in
our culture and that's really what the
founders about and just to see how it's
evolved from like it was like a counter
it really was like fresh whatever to
like garbage now but good garbage it's
just interesting it is interesting I
just the day that McDonald's goes out
like well no it's not it's not okay but
it will be so sad I think the biggest
company in the world it is and it's I
mean it's helped so many families like I
mean I just love it and the Ronald
McDonald House oh yes Olivia works with
them a lot so we've gone up there yes
that they do there is amazing
so I'm Ronald McDonald like he's not
really there like guy anymore remember
all the commercials you know what I'm
glad because there's something creepy
about him totally the hair was giving
redheads a bad name what's wrong with
red hair know what something it was red
first of all honestly redheads are
Orange your hair isn't red it's it's
orange like let's be real yeah like just
like from a color standpoint so he had
actual red hair look from a box and
that's why it was creepy
I agree okay I agree and someone should
really talk about the fact like redheads
don't have red hair they have orange
hair okay but if you come in orange head
I'll punch you know right but you do
have orange hair like the color of your
hair is orange yes
like on a color wheel it's orange okay
okay okay orange I'm happy birthday
aren't you glad I didn't say are intense
happy birthday big man actually big I
hope you all celebrate get out there get
a Big Mac this is actually not sponsored
but it should be totally um I hope you
celebrate well they may not remember
when McDonald's did a Coachella house
with like skinny girls yeah that was
funny that was hilarious not in tune
I'll tell you if they were into and they
would have had me running that whole
house and I just bring all my friends
who actually eat McDonald's yeah it
looks like a dream like they literally
every meal was catered by McDonald's and
you just know those [ __ ] were like
eating the lettuce off burgers stop I
would win so he's like some of them do
eat burgers and they just look like that
and like I just say to him they want you
to think you know there are people that
eat burgers and look like that like
kendall Jenner Chucky's she wants you to
think that homegirl is definitely
naturally thin and she definitely is a
burger like once every six months till I
take a picture with it but she's not
like having burgers for lunch while
she's on set no no I don't know I don't
know it's just out there I'm really
struggling as you can tell um they've
been final story before we bring out the
man of the hour
bull is in with Apple is within striking
distance of a trillion-dollar market
value o me this yesterday oh my god I
thought you're gonna be like who cares
know who does care because all their
products are absolute [ __ ] and I have an
iPhone 10 that was so expensive that I
regret buying literally every day of my
life because it freezes my phone freezes
about once a week and the only way to
get it to unfreezes to wait for it to
die isn't it terrible I can't even turn
it off that's a big time someone until
it dies or like put put on the morning
because rosin well I could call you may
be cooking Mia literally I faced ng once
and it never hung up and I had to wait
six hours for my phone to die just so
that I could end the [ __ ] call with
you I couldn't call anyone else iPhone
10 is the worst thing that ever happened
to me so do you think that the next your
next phone your next purchase will be
the iPhone 11 or a samsung galaxy no
it's not gonna be samsung galaxy but
I'll never be an [ __ ] who is the
first person to buy a new phone I'm
never never wait for iPhone 10 version
two I'm the [ __ ] who has the old
phone with an old charger that's better
and then at some point Apple had
programs your phone to stop working
right so that you had the battery for
updates won't work with the old phone
and the software update won't be
compatible with the old phone like
honestly Apple being a trillion dollar
company is built on a scam like their
products are [ __ ] well not even that
like their products could use help but
it's like what they do with their
chargers and all of that is and their
headphones like it's so frustrating it's
like we're all buying your products like
why do you need us to spend even more
money why do I have to have a million
charge you're sitting on my house and
it's like you're not gonna throw away a
charger so now I have iPhone 4 charger
iPhone 5 or iPhone 6 charger riddle me
this why did I have the newest phone and
the newest laptop and neither of them
can use any of the same cords there's
not in my new brand new computer there's
not a USB port thing I took get a
[ __ ] converter same and it took me I
didn't know that until I needed the USB
port so for the patreon episode and
we're like crunch for time and bro my
god I was literally like task rabbiting
Apple cords and going up to the Apple
store it was crazy
so I have the newest phone and the
newest computer you'd think they'd be
somewhat compatible I can't even use the
same pair of headphones I have to win
here right I have to use charging
advanced or my phone but then the brand
new computer has an old-school iPhone
aux aux like [ __ ] [ __ ] what
frustrates me about the stories that
they're building this trillion dollar
market value on the backs of chargers
and headphones because like you should
need that extra money if you you're the
most value I did it in the beginning
like it was forcing people to buy the
charges but now we're all on board we're
buying the Apple products regardless so
make it easy for us it's not cool I'm
done and I keep buying like different
converters and [ __ ] on Amazon that
aren't real Apple products like I just
got this thing you can't do that I just
got this thing punish you I know I just
got this thing that plugs into the phone
and it gives you two so you could charge
and listen to music at the same time you
get on Amazon I thought on Amazon and
it's working but I know it's gonna be
easy an apple certified some Amazon
products or apples I don't believe that
it is but are the chargers I buy our
Apple certified because it breaks their
phone it's just so crazy and we're so
and we're so reliant
yeah and we're just like we're just
we're compliant we're like oh yeah
whatever
that's just Apple but like I'm always on
the tail end of technology updates which
is weird because I'm like such a modern
woman but I had a blackberry until 2013
and I still have the iPhone 7 not even
the plus and I'm and I'm happy the best
one I ever had that I never should have
gotten written rid of was the a plus can
you go back to it I still have it it
works why don't I go back to it cuz like
I don't know I just have this one yeah
and it's nice to have a good fun and
once you like don't turn a phone on for
like two weeks it's broken ed yeah but
it's nice to have a good phone like in
my drawer like if anything were to
happen like I just have a good backup
phone but it doesn't have like service
or anything nobody you put your SIM card
like and not have to buy a whole info do
I have a SIM card I don't know I don't
know and is where I lose everything so
here's the deets the iPhone maker is
currently worth about nine hundred and
thirty five billion dollars and the
stock needs to go up more than seven
percent for it to make for it to top the
mark most but if Apple Wow's investors
when it reports earnings Tuesday there's
a chance it could become the first US
company to cross the trillion dollar
mark wow that's a big deal for you yeah
like just for the US you know like what
is a trillion it's a hundred billion a
thousand billion it's a thousand and
then six more zeros no no it's a million
in the six more zeros a million okay no
so you bitching so you get to 999
million you get to a billion so if you
get to 999 billion you get to a trillion
so it's a thousand billions
yeah interesting it's a hundred thousand
billions it's no it's a thousand
hun mm yeah thousand billion jagged you
know the difference between a million
and a billion dollars yes if you have a
good note I was gonna say it because I'm
gonna [ __ ] it up and it's somewhat about
about you know but the difference
between the million the billion dollars
if you have a million dollars you can
live comfortably for three years and
spend $300 a day that doesn't sound
right
no sorry okay sorry for three years you
spend a thousand dollars a day that's it
if you have a million dollars if you
have a billion dollars you could spend a
thousand dollars a day for 300 years I
think I don't know that sound right it
sounds sort of right it's like a
limerick like that just google it [ __ ]
off and it really puts things into
perspective how much I need a billion
dollars honestly I mean I don't know if
this is Ansari insider trading but given
this news we should all be buying Apple
stock right but I think that's what like
but then the stock goes up and then it's
a self-fulfilling prophecy cool go in
right maybe someone leaked this so that
it goes stocks are so crazy
why don't when I was at the stock
exchange back you know when I was a
respective comedian um I went on CNBC
went no no MSNBC no I will play shark
tank and no yes cm EC and it was [ __ ]
Valley and it was the day that snapchats
IPO in public and I'm sitting in hair
and makeup and like I realize like I
know nothing I don't even know that IPS
stands for and I texted someone who was
smart and I was like what's IPO and I'm
like what should I say and then the girl
came back she's like but they you'll
have to talk about it like I need a
smart stuff I'm like thank you it was
just more about I can't attack it's so
crazy what like milestones in life art
but that was like the coolest thing you
ever did and by the way I knew when it
was happening that it was like gonna be
the coolest thing I ever did so I was
like actually excited I had no clue cuz
all my Kogi friends like work in finance
CNBC plays on the TV's all day so lamely
finance channel everyone I knew texted
me about it him and you did such a good
job when I got off that literally the
most random text messages no it was so
cool and then I think that other coolest
thing that you did was billboard yeah
yeah yeah no I also watch out live oh
yeah I always forgot that on my list of
top cool things but it's literally
number one oh yeah speaking of watch out
inside Daniel I host bartending
yesterday so we're gonna ask him all
about it I feel like Andy definitely
like loves him oh for sure but I'm out
let's say man you guys are southern term
savanna fans and you've a question for
Daniel about the show but the Cassavetes
business anything make sure to leave a
comment on base
on Instagram on YouTube I mean we'll do
our absolute best together Tim we are
going to take a brief pause we'll be
back in like three to four minutes it's
Danielle so stay tuned
it's 11:11 make a wish
you
we are back with the toast of Savannah
Daniel echoes from southern charm but
who is actually our first time third
timer welcome back for the third time
thank you so much I could be scared I'm
amazing I feel great
you just sparked ended watch happens
live yeah it couldn't be any better it
was really really fun last night
it seems so fine we were just talking
about Claudia did it once and it's a
great time ever it was amazing andis a
total trip really a view I feel like I
feel like you've got some kind of
connection you know we hung out at the
Grateful Dead for the Dead and company
in Denver like two weeks ago and after
the show with John Mayer and everyone
and the band and everything and we had
like just a really fun time yes
do you drive me up to anything about
your hair I feel like um he did not but
he was really really really nice and so
yeah buddy loves him I don't he's
amazing tell us about your hair I think
that's what we got the mousse and a
little bun that's probably we got so
much questions about tell me about your
hair routine when you're filming do you
take extra care in it like what what do
you do are you ever gonna put it any
more so wear it up or do you wear it
downwards um so I really like it down
but every time I've ever asked anyone
what they think they always want me to
put it up so it's kind of like I wear
down to be a rebel but I wrap it up to
like not look insane all right I look
kind of like a homeless man when it's
down yeah yeah so you always have that
option you can wear it down around the
house and really yourself because we're
gonna walked in here we thought you cut
it yeah I didn't recognize you with like
and that's kind of also I like it
because I like to be a chameleon yes I
like to be able to just like you know
put it out maybe even put it over the
face can really just go anywhere no one
recognized me or then put it up you're
very professional and then yeah you're
up to work right um
Chad changes every day that's so fun no
idea I don't really have a routine for
me it's more just like I get it wet and
then I brush it and then that's kind of
like the only stable thing that occurs
right rushing it that's most important
yeah you have it it does not
that's like the number-one world just
brush your hair okay do you wash it
every day absolutely not yeah oh well
yeah I think we say absolutely like
you're disgusting no nobody let's take
we don't have that much no take me
because what I shoot for and the by the
way it's healthier to actually build up
like natural oils exactly I was told
that and I listened to her professional
good it's all working out for you thank
you this season of southern charm
Savannah is shaping up to be a very very
good one there's a lot of a few changes
some new cast members yes totally who I
like very much I agree
Brandon was just like a no-brainer
Brandon is absolutely amazing he's
literally one of my favorite people in
all of Savannah he's made for television
he is he's perfect and I love Haygood
she seems like the type of girl who like
all of these southern boys are looking
for like their dream girl like I want to
set her up with Chef from regular
southern charm have they met uh I think
they probably met they've definitely
he's dating someone correct she is
dating someone yeah but he's not on the
show he's not on the show and he's not
coming to me he's not going to be really
good guy about great dude how was her
sake business because it's the smartest
idea I've ever heard her family owns a
rice plantation and she's turned like
she's turning all the rags into Sakai so
they can have like more further business
coolest thing about her sake business
and it is actually I guess with all the
details we've learned about Sakae lately
is that apparently the right
pronunciation is sex okay okay okay
which is interesting because clearly
we've been hearing sake no yeah Japanese
are something I'm sorry yeah we've got
everything okay so the coolest thing
about it is it's really really good like
I actually love sucky like I've always
loved it I love the Japanese culture and
I drink tons of it when I go out to
restaurants and stuff and hers is
amazing and I think she's gonna do a
really good job yeah super tasty
I'm the right show like she got it all
figured out and I really want just good
things for her and her sake and her
family's farm cuz it's so nice if she
has enough rice and her family's farm to
serve sake to the entire world it's like
I'm famous for thousand per family
24,000 eat no no no no no her family's
farm is larger than Rhode Island yes
what literally it's the craziest like
that is Bravo being in tune with what's
necessary in terms of cast
people like I don't need to see that guy
who pretended to be a congressman you
know like I need to go I need a girl
with the farm that's bigger than the
state of Rhode Island what is that
that's what I'm looking for when I go to
watch southern Johnson animal hard I
need someone who was the best Jewish
person in so that like that's what I
need a hundred percent and you are
representing us so well so well what's
so interesting about your trajectory
this season is that you've avoided
falling into that like southern charm
boy rabbit hole where you just like get
don't working get don't work rely on the
show go to bars every night like you're
up an atom every day oh yeah at 6:00
a.m. working out while your friends are
like dilly dallying well not all of them
are dilly dallying but I mean like you
know I've got this kind of was this a
random opportunity to came up out of
nowhere you know no I didn't like have a
plan like I want to be on a southern try
and be on TV so we're trying to me and
my team we're trying to build a
billion-dollar company and I can't
exactly go out and party and then not
wake up early and go to work so we do it
and it's just it's not working so what
is the company that you're trying to
build so it's called an we're actually
brewed rebranding right now it's called
get cases like every brand love a good
reread yeah get cases ok so we sell
cases to attorneys like any kind of
attorney that wants you know a defective
products defective drugs how much they
pay for it different prices for each
case because they're different in a
supply and demand it's a product
magnetising can you buy case you're like
$10 no what's like the lowest lowest we
can probably there's some low ones for
about 250 350 and then what's the
highest like a really hot one we've sold
a hot one for 10 to 12 thousand that's
so crazy amazing idea yeah it is so
we're productizing the marketing since
I'm an attorney going to spend all their
time trying to do marketing and figure
how to get business we're allowing the
attorneys to be attorneys go to your job
tell us what kind of cases you want to
work on let us go do everything we have
a call center that signs it up and then
copy the contract sign we'll send it to
you and again it allows the attorneys to
go do attorney work and it also helps
like the average man who I can't find an
attorney that's why our vision is no
claimant without a claim Wow
that's a good idea that's an amazing
it's so rare that you hear like a
business idea of someone on a reality
show and it's actually good
and it's not like a branded wine you
know right good for you that's amazing
so last week you told your family about
it and they were like it's supportive
had you told them about the idea yet
what an a think about the idea they've
known about the ideas kind of been in
our heads for a while but it's you know
everything takes timing is everything
so the idea has been and our families
our discussions for a long time but it
finally it's you know it's taking a very
long time to get my brother's law firm
to the point where I really didn't need
to be there because working you're
building a company and working yourself
out of a job is really difficult like
it's you're a very important role yeah
so I've took me probably seven years to
do that and then now I've exited that
role and I think it's all good and I
think that the new company is also going
to help the law firm as well
definitely they'll work in conjunction
it's gonna be great
how has the show affected your family's
business positively yeah I think it
actually has been very positive my
brother's come off very well on the show
he hasn't been on a ton but he has been
on Sonny's cut some and he's come off
well and I think that most people are
appreciative of actually seeing who we
really are you know and understanding
they're like we're cool people and like
we work really hard and we've had
clients even call us and been like we
saw you guys on Bravo killer on bravo
y'all are obviously legit like no it's
so funny that's great no it's weird to
go to Compton litigation in Savannah we
would call you a hundred percent if I
got it like a DUI I call you at five in
the morning to like Channel come pick me
up please
bring you I just so everyone really
wants to know like your dating situation
cuz I'm what we're seeing on the show is
you're not dating anyone but this is now
six months later yeah totally are you
seeing anyone no I'm single but the last
time you were here you were seeing
someone I was seeing someone but what
did that serious yeah that was serious
yeah yeah it just ended up being that we
weren't I don't think that I think we
both realized that we weren't right for
each other in the long run and then we
you know we are still great friends
today and very close play tennis
together and stuff but we yeah we just
realized we weren't probably gonna get
married and maybe we should you know
just be friends and help each other and
other parts of life that's really the
greatest way to break up it's like we're
not going anywhere like let's stop
wasting each other's time exactly and
you can remain friends right it's
wonderful but only one person feels that
way you know I always want to remain
friends yeah what are you looking for if
have any choice we have tons of toasters
and they're all gonna ride into your
hands and you are worthy of it yes so if
someone were to slide into your DMS what
would you be looking for a from an
aesthetic standpoint and then B from
just like a personality standpoint I
mean from a personality standpoint like
honestly my number one quality is
someone who wants to make other people
happier than themselves and care about
others and more than themselves and kind
of do that which makes we all I think
there's a lot of like people say you
know you're looking for what's in your
mother and your grandmother stuff and
like my mom is like literally the
sweetest human being on earth wait
that's so weird that you just said that
because as I was making my bed today I
don't know why I was like you know and
you just a dream about like potential
things you could say on the toast yeah I
was like talking about how like they say
you really like you marry your dad or if
you're a boy you marry and like Ben
couldn't have done the opposite cuz
Ben's mom is literally an angel from God
she's just we dispersed never said a
full-time volunteer like she's literally
an angel like I'm the exact opposite
like I've never volunteered in my life
and that's just so weird that you said
that cuz I was thinking that this
morning I'm like they people really do
marry like you're marrying your dad
totally like that's true but that didn't
happen with me well Ben and daddy are
yeah but I'm not Dead's mama couldn't
we're at polar opposites sorry to
interrupt but sometimes there's
sometimes the opposite part works as
well there's like yes I want to be yells
at definitely so you've kind of been
staying above the fray this season which
I believe is the best place to be like
you don't have any pits I'm sure
watching the show back like no anxiety
no not at all so but your friends do I
have a little bit of anxiety coming up
but I think you guys will have to see
that there is some you know I'm not
perfect as no one is but there are some
scenes where I definitely get a little
bit nervous about what I'm saying but at
the end of the day I'm speaking the
truth so I'm not actually afraid of it I
just I hope that it comes off in the way
that I want it to you know when you're
deeply intoxicated trying to communicate
an important issue sometimes Steve your
words are yeah perfect that's the worst
like you just like you know what you
want to say but you can't and then the
message is lost even if you had the
right sense and then you're just like
yelling it dancing it's always it's not
really about what you say it's how you
deliver it and if you do it in a way
that's like incoherent or drunk I mean
like you lost your point even if you had
a good point to start with yeah good it
will a good a point on this one is that
my hair was definitely down oh you got
your hair down yeah
I let my hair completely down and out
okay so very Catherine and Lisle where
do they stand today because I truly
can't keep up and watching it it seems
as though there's something going on
that no one is saying and I'm confused
yeah you're on just to let you know we
are also all confused so like you're on
the exact same page as we are and we
don't really know what's going on
because like I said the rubber band
effect and they said that last night you
know and I don't think you understood
what that meant which besides me which
happens all the time yeah but what if I
was it they'd pull apart and so like
they pull apart and I think that it's
working well and they start to like be
single and then like they get apart and
then catherine sees that they're
becoming apart and she takes these claw
looking things and snaps the rubber band
back got in there together and then they
repeat the process 15 years the process
for torture that's crazy
it's absolutely insane I don't know how
one of them haven't the fact that they
talk about not going to therapy I don't
know how they don't get it there because
I think I'd probably be yeah it's scary
yeah see I don't know I don't know I
want all we want oh we're right for each
other no not at all I think well I think
Lyle needs to go Lyle needs to actually
break up with Catherine when Catherine
tries to like get back in his life he
needs to say no and he used to go spend
some time by himself and find someone
else because they're not right for each
other
yeah like she likes him he broke up with
her last night and she was like okay
yeah exactly she doesn't seem like she
likes him until he's hanging out and
talking to another ray and then she
loves him man and as soon as he likes
her back it's it's sixteen years talking
about two years right and he proposed at
the end of last season she ran away oh
and she try energy it doesn't admit that
it happened you can ask her to her face
that scene as opposed if he proposed her
and she will literally say he no he
didn't she would let him say it if
that's the worst thing that is the worst
one they were murdering the ap2 I love
Kevin great for you Catherine great I
just don't understand the Lyle side but
I'd like her as a person on the show and
I think she's a great like character
she's also made for TV like just so
interesting and she's super fun
Catherine's a great girl she can be tons
of fun and great to hang out with they
just need to be
separate and then you get on the line
and go do themselves 100% and but would
you say the same about Hannah and Louie
Hannah and Louie I think are very
different I think they both are what
they love each other and I do think that
they should be with each other but the
problem is is that Louie's got this
crazy startup company that he's putting
his entire heart and soul into and it's
just very hard for him to balance and
Louie's a lot like me to where it's like
it's very hard to balance when you only
have a certain amount of time in the day
and we're really trying very hard and
yes I forget sometimes to do what I need
to do but like at first you told me do
you want to be two more samhita more
serious now I am more serious and now
I've got this crazy company they're
trying to grow and now I'm too serious
and don't have enough time but I think
they're I think they're good I know that
they do love each other and they both
are like my two best friends in the
world so I do want to say happy and that
would stink for you if they actually
broke up okay you know to take whose
side would shake both you have to take a
side I would but it always have to take
a side I can't not take Louisa six years
no choice are you wearing his socks does
he leave his socks around the apartment
what do you think wow you're good are
only wear socks whatever so do you get
free sock so I mean choose to be if I go
into his drawer just take them which I
definitely do all the time but he knows
that he's not he's not like surprise
right that's funny these are these were
actually these didn't even come out yet
so I get the pre oh I need exclusive
maybe we'll send you guys some some
please I love stuff you got we just find
the female not we it's not part of that
kind of feel like I am because I do help
him test you see yeah but he just made
female athletic socks oh cool just can't
we just got I don't even last week I
don't wanna check it we don't need that
letting socks no we're not I thought it
we need size when it's odd socks are
hard to come by
they are specially matches yeah make
this happen
oh yeah seven I do
banana leaves on them yes pink cute we
should well app can continue to staying
above like above the [ __ ] it's
really it's nice to watch someone on one
of these shows who just like is in tune
with reality and like it's still you
know pounding the pavement waking up at
6:00 a.m. going to work and we love it
and is using the show to like further
your business right but you're not just
relying on the show it's it's doing it
for funny I'm doing to hang out my
friends and like it's good it's
enjoyable you don't so what more can we
expect this season without spoiling too
much um I think things get a little bit
wild I mean I think that y'all's Kathryn
and Lyle questions are very on point and
I think that like yeah like I said
earlier everyone asks that question
everyone wants to know that answer so I
think we dig pretty deep into it and try
to get as real as we possibly can and
then I also think that um there's some
other kind of unexpected events that
might occur that I think everyone will
enjoy I think it becomes R I think it's
a good show and I think it ends really
well and strong and there's some fun
yeah new characters and I do think the
new characters really bring a great
sense of just like fresh air because I
think Brandon is really is one of my
favorite people in Savannah and hey
goods awesome and I lived like two
houses next to her for the whole year
and she's yeah she's really great and
cool there's a good job of freshing up
and we're very i we're glad that ashley
is no longer a cast member but it seems
as though she appears this season yes
she does appear at some point this
season the cartel when that's gonna
happen but yeah I definitely sit down
and talk to her and I try to just take
it with her I don't really see her ever
I mean I'm friends I'm definitely
friends with her but like I'm not gonna
let go we don't like go out to eat
together and hang out yeah except for
that one time
except for that ones that I went out to
eat what do you I had a I had two
sandwiches because it was such a good
restaurant French cook from Paris can't
believe Anna opened a cafe and I had
some quiche and I also had I had [ __ ]
I'm Jewish I can't say okay I know maybe
but it's a bacon egg and cheese were
forgiving people I know it just it hurts
my heart but it's bacon I just honestly
you know me shame on you I know alright
I'll work harder this year
yes exactly sure thank you for joining
us if people want to keep up with you
and your business and your hair where
can they follow you an extra them they
can follow me on Instagram
eaters underscore ride and then Facebook
Daniel I Colts 2 HS 2 HS e IC HHH yeah I
hope yeah well think what I say that is
normal get confused yeah totally and if
you want to see Daniel you can watch him
Monday nights on Bravo on southern charm
Savannah thank you for being here next
week cool thanks for being our first
their timer thank you guys for watching
make sure you're following the morning
tous on Facebook Instagram YouTube and
Twitter at the morning toast and I will
be here tomorrow but Jackie's gonna be
here with alien from betches so it's
gonna be a good time we have a whole
slated schedule of programming premium
content only so make sure you tuned in
for the rest of the week I will see you
guys later
you